he arrived about 10 o'clock this morning
arrived via the players tunnel the
player's entrance around at the
Stratford and the other side of uh
Manchester United's Old Trafford ground
here and spent around about an hour or
so inside with his delegation they were
given a tour of the stadium no doubt a
tour of the Museum tour of the trophy
room as well resplendent with the latest
edition the efl cup which was put in
there earlier on this month and then
after he'd been here for an hour or so
and a quick tour of the the club shop it
was off to Carrington off to the club's
state of the art training facility he
looked in a very relaxed mood as he came
out there were a lot of press
photographers TV cameras and so on to
watch him as he made his way from the uh
from the Old Trafford Club shop into the
car park into his car and Away to
Carrington and it's at Carrington where
we understand there will be a number of
presentations by the Manchester United
Representatives they need to show the
club in as strong a light as possible
they want the people who are interested
in buying the Club to up their bids we
know that uh Sheikh jasim was uh was
here yesterday his delegation spent
about 10 hours here yesterday and we
understand that that bid for 100 of the
club is around four and a half billion
pounds we think that the ineos bridge as
far as we know all of these bids are
wrapped in non-disclosure agreements
it's also worth around four and a half
billion pounds but it's thought that
that could just be for the Glazer steak
the 69 that the glazers own not for the
club as a whole could also mean some
borrowing as well by ineos in order to
to get this deal over the line although
it's understood that any borrowing that
does take place to try and reach the
asking price for the club will be uh
passed on to ineos rather than pass on
to the club that was what the glazers
did that's one of the reasons one of the
many reasons why the fans are so angry
with the glazes was because they
borrowed money to buy the club and then
passed that debt onto the club itself
rather than carrying it as their own
personal debt so the Manchester United
Representatives will be trying to show
exactly what the club is worth to show
that it is worth the 6 billion that the
glazers say it is if you look at it on
paper purely as a financial exercise
purely as a company not taking its
history and it's uh and the fact that
it's a major football club into account
it's probably not worth half of the four
and a half billion so say the financial
experts that's uh that's being offered
but it is a trophy asset as it's as it's
known so Jim is a massive mantis United
fan he was born and brought up only
about five miles away or so from the
ground and this would be a dream come
true for him it's a real passion project
for him he says he wants to put the
Manchester back into Manchester United
and the fans would certainly be pleased
to hear that in terms of the financial
situation the fans probably more
interested in the bid from Qatar because
that cancels the debt and buys the club
in its entirety we'll move into stage
three of the process once all of these
meetings have happened fresh bids will
be put in and then the glazers will
decide whether or not and who they want
to sell it to